mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
suppose x squared is equal to 17x plus y
and y squared is equal to x plus 17y
if x is not equal to y what is the value
of the square root of x squared plus y
squared plus one equal to
i thank uzla from india for the
suggestion
a similar problem was asked to students
who were approximately 15 years old and
only six percent answered correctly
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
you might be tempted to solve for x and
y directly
but instead of doing that we will use a
standard trick of manipulating these two
equations
first we'll subtract the second equation
from the first equation
the left hand side is x squared minus y
squared and the right hand side is equal
to 16x minus 16y
we can factor the left-hand side into
the quantity x plus y multiplied by the
quantity x minus y
we can factor 16 on the right hand side
to get 16 multiplied by x minus y
now since x is not equal to y
x minus y is not equal to zero
therefore in this equation we can divide
both sides by x minus y
they'll cancel out and we get x plus y
is equal to 16.
we will then go back to our original two
equations and this time we'll add the
two equations together
we get x squared plus y squared is equal
to 18x plus 18y
this means x squared plus y squared is
equal to 18 multiplied by the quantity x
plus y
but we already know that x plus y is
equal to 16 so we can substitute that in
we then have 18 is equal to 17 plus 1
and 16 is equal to seventeen minus one
we thus get a difference of squares
x squared plus y squared is equal to
seventeen squared minus one squared
one squared is equal to one of course
this is the case if x is not equal to y
from here we add 1 to both sides of the
equation so x squared plus y squared
plus 1 is equal to 17 squared
we then want the square root of this and
this will be equal to 17
and that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]